darüber wollen wir sprechen bei uns im
studio jetzt jan schäfer bild
politikchef kurve der hoffnung also aber
zur hoffnung trägt natürlich auch das
impfen bei und die allgemeine
impfpflicht wird auch viel in der
politik diskutiert was kannst du uns
darüber berichten wie sind da gerade bei
der union die meinung naja es gibt wild
durcheinander muss man sagen es gibt
teile in der union auch in der
unionsfraktion die sind ganz klar für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht wir wissen
dass von ministerpräsidenten
beispielsweise auch von markus söder dem
csu-chef aber es gibt auch andere
ministerpräsidenten der union
beispielsweise den
cdu-ministerpräsident nordrhein
westfalen hendrik wüst der auch für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ist und auch der
fraktionsvorsitzende ralph brinkhaus im
bundestag ist ganz klar der meinung wir
brauchen diese allgemeine impfpflicht
aber es gibt auch andere es gibt auch
gegenstimmen es gibt viele die sich
zurückhaltend wir wissen beispielsweise
von friedrich merz den künftigen cdu
chef dass er wenn überhaupt für ein
stufenmodell ist also beispielsweise
ältere die dann pflicht mäßig geimpft
werden sollten also eine sehr diffizile
unterschiedliche gemenge lage
durch den bundestag durch genau wie auch
durch familien durch das arbeitsleben
und so weiter wir sehen aber noch eine
ganz andere spaltung aktuell im
bundestag die einen unten die anderen
oben unten die geimpften oben auf der
sonder tribüne die ungeimpften die
dürfen nicht mehr runter in den
plenarsaal ein absoluter tabubruch das
hat so nicht gegeben die müssen oben
setzen die werden sozusagen gemacht hat
man sieht jetzt wer die ungeimpften dort
im bundestag sind aber es geht hinter
den kulissen dann mit dieser trennung
weiter ja ja es gibt einen du hast das
wort tabubruch gerade schon genannt aber
es gibt einen wirklich absoluten
tabubruch den es gestern nachmittag
gegeben hat bei der sitzung des
auswärtigen ausschusses da durfte ein
ungeimpfte abgeordneter an diesem geheim
tagenden gremium nicht mal mehr
teilnehmen also der konnte auch nicht
zugeschaltet werden sondern der durfte
diesen raum nicht betreten weil er nicht
geimpft waren nach unseren informationen
hatte er ein negatives testergebnis
sogar dabei trotzdem wurde beschlossen
er dürfte an dieser sitzung nicht
teilnehmen da ist ein absoluter
tabubruch neben reden wider wir reden
von einem fdp- abgeordneten dass es
joachim wundrak
der mitglied dieses ausschusses ist
dabei darf nicht nur durfte gestern
nicht rein und das ist natürlich
dramatisch also wir sehen dass dieses
corona virus offenbar auch jetzt die
herzkammer unserer demokratie nämlich
den bundestag so dramatisch infiziert
hat dass abgeordnete nicht weit das
recht ausüben dürfen was sie haben
nämlich ihr mandat auszuüben sind frei
gewählt und hier entscheidet offenbar
jetzt eine mehrheit des bundestages oder
von abgeordneten darüber ob jemand
anders an einer sitzung teilnehmen darf
oder nicht das ist ein skandal lasst uns
darüber sprechen mit dem cdu
bundestagsabgeordneten und künftigen
stellvertreter wahrscheinlich von
friedrich merz mit carsten linnemann
ernst zugeschaltet ist schön guten tag
herr lehmann hallo erweisen jan schäfer
ja geradezu gehört der mächtig verärgert
ist über diese praxis dort im bundestag
die einen oben die anderen unten im
plenarsaal geimpfte die unten sitzen
ungeimpfte die gar nicht mehr rein
dürfen in den saal und jetzt sogar auch
eine ungeimpfte abgeordneter der nicht
mal mehr an der ausschusssitzung
teilnehmen darf finden sie dass alles so
richtig
nein bin ich nicht die arbeitsfähigkeit
des parlamentes muss muss immer zwingend
hergestellt werden und auch sein und ein
abgeordneter der nicht geimpft ist
stellen aber ein negativen test hat muss
teilnehmen können und deswegen halte ich
das für einen fehler
wir haben ausschuss seele wo man sitzen
kann auf der tribüne man kann das
ähnlich machen wie im deutschen
bundestag müssen nicht ausgeschlossen
werden ich halte das für einen fehler
und das sollte in zukunft so nicht mehr
vorkommen
jetzt den aktuellen fall halten sie für
ein fehler auch die trennung im
bundestag also unten und oben oder
finden sie das wiederum richtig nein es
geht mir um die arbeitsfähigkeit und ich
finde wo es eine arbeitsfähigkeit geben
mussten es im deutschen parlament
deswegen kann man das so machen wie im
deutschen bundestag aber die
abgeordneten müssen teilnehmen und das
amt in dem fall der gerade von den
schäfers fixiert wurde war das nicht der
fall nämlich gestern im auswärtigen
ausschuss dann muss in zukunft der
auswärtige ausschuss dort tag wo es eine
bühne gibt wo man das machen kann es
kann nicht sein dass in höchsten
parlament deutschlands oder auch in
anderen elementen in der legislative
abgeordnete ausgeschlossen werden wer
einen negativen test hat muss dann auf
die tribüne gehen und muss zumindest
dann
vollumfänglich auch teilnehmen können ja
das heißt was machen wir jetzt ganz
konkret mit dem fall sie sind dagegen
alle mal aber das schlägt ja hohe wellen
das heißt das darf nicht mehr vorkommen
man muss doch den bundestag wieder
zusammenführen wir reden im ganzen land
darüber wie wir nicht spalten sondern
versöhnen
absolut deswegen sage ich ja auch hier
klar meine meinung und hoffe dass das
auch bei
den präsidenten- vize-präsidenten bei
der präsidentin des deutschen
bundestages gehört wird und dass andere
sich melden und die ich höre gibt es ja
auch eine debatte darüber und sie tun ja
auch die übrigens dazu dass über dieses
reden damit in zukunft diese
abgeordneten dann auch teilnehmen können
wir möchten mit ihnen noch über ein
anderes thema sprechen frankreich stößt
nur halb so viel co2 aus wie deutschland
erzeugt erzeugt aber 70 prozent seines
stroms aus kernenergie muss deutschland
über einen wiedereinstieg in die
kernkraft nachdenken
das problem ist verlor ich habe mich
gestern mit jemandem unterhalten der
viele ahnung hat und die ganzen
betreiber der kernkraftwerke
kennt wie schalten ja dieses jahr ein
kernkraftwerk ab was das effizienteste
der welt ist insofern ist diese
entscheidung bitter gewesen es war
meines erachtens 1 weder das problem ist
nun warten wir werden jetzt kein
betreiber finden der in zukunft ein
kernkraftwerk wieder betreiben will das
heißt sie müssen sven dunlop staatlich
machen die lösung wäre meines erachtens
ganz klar europa wir brauchen
photovoltaik aus dem süden
aus nicht nur aus der sahara sondern
auch aus den südlichen europäischen
ländern wir haben gas pipelines wir
müssen das über wasserstoff
transportieren wir müssen endlich weg
von der nationalen denke hin zu
europäischen jahr zur globalen denke
entweder wir schaffen die klimafrage
global zu regeln global in den griff zu
bekommen oder gar nicht nun hat der herr
lindemann
der neue bundeswirtschaftsminister
robert habeck diese woche sein plan
vorgestellt ist ein nationaler
masterplan gewesen und aus dem geht
unter anderem hervor dass bis 2030 80
prozent unseres stroms aus erneuerbaren
energien also aus wind und sonne sowie
sie gerade sagten auch dann kommen soll
das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat das einmal
hochgerechnet und kommt auf eine ihre
zahl alle vier stunden müsste um das zu
erreichen eigentlich dann künftig in
deutschland ein neues windrad ans netz
gehen ist das realistisch
meines erachtens ist das nicht
realistisch es ist immer einfach in der
politik ziele zu setzen müsse man auf
achten für politiker ist am einfachsten
irgendwelche ziele zu setzen aber die
entscheidende frage ist ja wie komme ich
dahin kann auch sagen ich will nächstes
jahr die champions league gewinnen aber
wenn ich nicht weiß mit welcher
mannschaft mit welcher truppe mit
welcher strategie mit welchem
spielsystem dann werde ich es nicht
schaffen und so ist es auch hier bei der
energiewende die unterstützenden habe
darin dass beispielsweise die
genehmigungsverfahren halbieren wollen
damit ihr im leitungsnetz aussteller da
vorankommen lehne man dann sagen sie
einmal ganz konkret auch wenn man das
jetzt wenn man die verfahren halbieren
möchte wie sieht ihr plan aus also
braucht deutschland mehr gaskraftwerke
das heißt ja auch dass eigentlich fast
zehnmal so viele leistungen aus
gaskraftwerken künftig kommen muss also
wie sicher deutschland wie muss die
bundesregierung die stromversorgung bis
2030 sichern wenn wir doch sehen dass
wir so massive probleme haben es ist
offenkundig dass bestreitet keiner mehr
das immer gaskraftwerke in deutschland
brauchen erster punkt zweiter punkt wir
müssen bei den genehmigungsverfahren
vorankommen müssen dann aber auch ja
auch mal zum teil ja eben meinung vor
ort vornehmen dass wir sagen denn der
leitungsausbau kommt brauchen wir
beispielsweise ein bundesgesetz wie wir
es damals gemacht haben nach der
wiedervereinigung beim ausbau der
verkehrsinfrastruktur wo wir sagen wir
beschließen hier bestimmte großen
projekte im bereich der energie
problematik sag ich jetzt mal und dann
wird das durchgezogen da gibt es
beispielsweise nur noch eine klage
instanz damit schneide ich eine
bürgerrechte ab aber es kann ja nicht
sein dass wir so lange brauchen die
beispielsweise auch in der verkehrs
14 26 jahre brauchen vom zwei stunden
aussuchen bei der bahnstrecke von
münchen nach berlin wenn wir so
weitermachen ja da machen wir uns nur
lächerlich in der welt weil wir immer
ziele vorgeben die aber nicht erreichen
ich kann nur sagen bei dem ganzen thema
planungs beschleunigen vieles mehr haben
wir auch in den letzten jahren große
ziele gesetzt haben auch vieles nicht
erreicht und das hängt einfach auch mit
themen zusammen bürgerproteste vor ort
dass man die zu lange laufen lässt dass
man einwände auch freigibt wenn schon
die entscheidung politisch getroffen ist
wie sieht es mit den naturschutz aus mit
atemschutz und vielen mehr und das sind
ja gerade die themen die auch wehtun in
der debatte aber die müssen wir führen
und werden wir nicht ein ziel erreichen
herr lehmann große ziele große projekte
kosten auch immer viel geld werden sich
habe ex pläne nur durch steuererhöhungen
finanzieren lassen ja das ist ja das
große problem insgesamt bei einem
projekten was jetzt hier gemacht das ist
ein bisschen unfair was im moment
gemacht wird uns mangelnder auszudrücken
man nutzt die pandemie aus um
geldquellen locker zu machen
beispielsweise für die energiepolitik
für die klimafrage und das ist
hochgradig gefährlich auch für die
nächsten generationen
ich bin gerade das beispiel gebracht
ausbau der strecke von münchen nach
berlin mit dem zug hat 26 jahre gedauert
das geld war immer vorrätig hätte
abgerufen werden können wurde aber nicht
abrufen weil man nicht fertig wir haben
in deutschland kein geldproblem sondern
wir haben offenkundig ein
umsetzungsproblem dass die verfahren so
lange laufen und vieles mehr und das
sollte die regierung anpacken anstatt
ikone krise jetzt als grund zu sehen um
sich zusätzlich zu verschulden um die
dinge auszugeben die kurzarbeitergeld
oder
unternehmenshilfen die mit corona zu tun
haben sondern sie stecken dieses geld in
andere punkte und das ist gefährlich wir
müssen den hunger des staates nach neuen
geldquellen grenzen auch in zeiten wie
diesen deutschland schneller machen sagt
carsten linnemann das muss die regierung
jetzt anpacken werde so schön wenn sie
es schon angepackt hätte auch in den
letzten jahrzehnten viel dank für das
gespräch wirtschaftsexperte und
demnächst stellvertreter von friedrich
merz carsten linnemann der hier die
harbeck pläne zerpflückt hat wir haben
es gerade schon rechts eingeblendet
gesehen wir schauen auf wichtigen termin
heute mittag auf eine pressekonferenz
von
unserem gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach zur corona lage in
deutschland ganz wichtig bleiben sie
dann 13 uhr ist das soweit dann wird er
informieren was omikron aktuell mit uns
macht denn wir fragen uns sind wir übern
berg mittlerweile oder sind wir kurz
davor über einen berg zu kommen anhand
der wichtigen kurve aus großbritannien
und die wollen wir uns anschauen ja das
mikro virus macht endlich schlaf
zumindest in großbritannien und dort
geht die zahl der korona infektion
kontinuierlich zurück gleichzeitig aber
stagnierende die krankenhauseinweisung
von komapatienten und wie sieht's aus in
deutschland dort steigen die zahlen
weiterhin dazu immer mehr maßnahmen ja
also die korona kurve der hoffnung aus
großbritannien die abfallende omikron
kurve die nehmen wir zum anlass zu
diskutieren mit unserem bild expertenrat
nämlich mit dem chef der kassen ärzte in
deutschland mit andreas gassen und dem
topf ihre logen klaus stöhr sonntag in
beiden montag hallo herr stört das ist
die kurve der hoffnung sagen wir bei
bild heute sagen sie dass auch
die kurve der öffnung des virus der
hoffnung ja es geht in die richtige
richtung ohne zweifel wir haben schon
gedacht wir haben über den bergen über
den berg heißt ja es gibt noch dieselbe
strecke wieder bergab da sind wir schon
ein stückchen weiter denken wir dass wir
jetzt vier fünftel durch die pandemie
durch sind weil die anpassung erfolgt
das video ist etwas milder die
krankheitsverläufe schweren etwas
seltener und das wichtigste die meisten
menschen am antikörper und werden jetzt
sehr schnell durch die omikron variante
weil sie leichter übertragbar ist auch
noch eine zusätzliche immunität bekommen
und die impfung und immunität natürlich
oben drauf wird die meisten dann so
vorbereiten dass wir dann einigermaßen
ruhig in die ende mai kommen und die
wird in diesem sommer sicherlich schon
da sein herr gas 12 g plus wurde nun
auch für den 10 saal des bundestags
verabschiedet macht das medizinisch
überhaupt sinn
na gut also die regel und zwei geld plus
wird ja sehr unterschiedlich
interpretiert also der stand den ich
kenne ist das doppelt gegen den test bei
müssen führte gilt das glaube ich nicht
das ist so ein bisschen der eine ein
kontroll wunsch eine kontrolle illusion
muss man wahrscheinlich sagen weil wir
erleben ja schon dass sich sehr viele
infektionen auch der schnelltest und
ziehen das liegt an der zuverlässigkeit
der schnellschätzung auch an der
wahrscheinlich nur kurzfristigen
nachweisbarkeit dann der jeweilige
infektion insofern kann man so was
sicherlich machen grundsätzlich glaube
ich ist zweig oder zwei gibt durchaus
ein mittel noch im sport treiben das
generell jetzt machen bundestag
losgelöst anwenden würde aber man muss
ich glaube ich auch klar machen dass das
keine richtig wirkliche sicherheit da
bietet das ist ein weiteres instrument
aber sie sind natürlich weit davon
entfernt damit infektionen sich
ausschließen zu können
lassen sie uns auch mit ihnen über die
kurve sprechen die kurve der hoffnung
wie sie auch herr stöhr gerade genannt
hat also jetzt sehen wir da aus
großbritannien dass die zahlen
zurückgehen und wir gucken alle wann ist
das in deutschland soweit nehmen sie das
schon irgendwo war in den praxen dass
ein bisschen entspannung reinkommt oder
sind wir da noch einige tage einige
wochen von entfernt
also dann kann er stört sich
qualifizierter was zu sagen ich habe mir
natürlich auch die studien angeschaut
habe bürgers virologen durchgehend sagen
die sagen wir haben offensichtlich eine
evolution des virus hin zu mehr
ansteckungen aber weniger krankheits
machen da prozent das ist erstmal gut
wir werden noch sicherlich weitere
anstieg der zahlen sehen ich denke wir
haben auch hier ein gewisses
verfälschtes bild weil beispielsweise
großbritannien deutlich mehr getestet
hat also ich glaube dass eine ganze
reihe infekt und unerkannt durch die
gegend laufen schon bei geimpfte in der
regel ja symptomatisch r kann also ich
glaube dass wir uns dass sich der
entspannung nähern was immer noch einem
punkt ist wir haben im bereich der
übersicht sich zwar mit 88 5 sehr hohe
im sport aber eben auch noch 15 prozent
dieser menschen sind nicht geben nikon
ist nicht ganz so gefährlich wie date
oder deutlich weniger gefährlich aber
das heißt natürlich nicht dass keiner
mehr schwer antwort und bei ungeimpften
ist die gefahr natürlich unverändert
noch da so das ist schön wäre wenn sich
von den über 60 noch möglichst viele
impfen ließen dann hätten wir
tatsächlich eine noch entspanntere
situation denn wir können so immer noch
nicht ausschließen dass bei den hohen
infektionszahlen eben auch dann ein sehr
kleiner prozentsatz ab ein gewisser
prozess wird eben auch schwer erkranken
ob intensiv ich muss man dann sehen und
das sind natürlich im wesentlichen
ungeimpfte von daher spricht vieles
dafür sich noch impfen zu lassen aber
grundsätzlich glaube ich auch dass wir
tatsächlich auf den letzten metern der
pandemie sind herr stöhr auf den letzten
metern der pandemie die impfpflicht
könnte natürlich dabei helfen wie ist
ihre meinung dazu wir sind sie
befürworter und würde das helfen dass
wir bald über den berg sind alle wenn
die impfpflicht helfen würde und wenn
die kollateralschäden in der
gesellschaft die man das jetzt geringer
sind als der nutzen den man erreichen
will dann wäre ja auch dafür aber das
ist aus meinem blickwinkel nicht der
fall allein die zeitliche komponente
spricht dagegen jemand das umgesetzt hat
die impfpflicht rechtlich und dann auch
sicherlich logistisch dann ist der
frühling schon da und dann ist wie durch
immunisierungen die natürliche durch
immunisierung durch und wir konnten
schon fast passiert also das muss man
auch im hinterkopf behalten und das
zweite mal natürlich noch wichtiger das
vielleicht braucht man dann eine
impfpflicht auch im herbst aus meiner
perspektive sehr wahrscheinlich nicht
weil dann der sehr vieler menschen nach
die natürliche immunisierung noch
obendrauf bekommen haben auf die impfung
hat mich über viele viele
übersichtlicher wir haben auch noch
impfen lassen und dann ist das niveau in
prenzlau dann empfiehlt man halt in
deutschland gegenüber 60 hier in anderen
portablen sich gegen korona impfen zu
lassen war neue variante hin oder her
das dann keinen unterschied mehr machen
deswegen ist ihr blick aus meinem
blickwinkel jetzt eigentlich in gewisser
art und wir alle tot geborenes kind man
trete zwar dass noch die ganze zeit
schon irgendwie denke ich wird das
abebben vielleicht nimmt die
bundesregierung migron als eigenen blatt
die sache auch langsam auslaufen zu
lassen diskussion schön wäre es wenn man
die den sprung nutzt und jetzt irgendwas
im kataster redet nicht um migranten
dann impfung durchzuziehen sondern dass
im katastophe nutzt für die zukunft für
die allen vielen anderen immunisierungen
die in deutschland noch nicht schon
gemacht nur noch kommen das wäre
phänomenal sein herzlichen dank an unser
bild expertenrat an den topf ihre logen
klaus stöhr und an den chef der
kassenärztlichen herzlichen dank